Jamie too hot in here.
Turn the AC up.
That bitch get it down to zero.
My man.
What's happening baby?
Welcome back.
Brought notes.
Yeah.
Just a couple of notes.
I don't want to repeat myself since the
last time because you're the only guest
ever in the history of this podcast that
is brought notes to make sure they don't
repeat themselves.
Yes.
They say it's the first time I do a
podcast.
This like or any other interview I never
go programmed or premeditated or
prepared whatsoever.
Just jump in,
but I think this is much more important.
It's Joe Rogan man and the ice man man.
And you are a big window and I'm still
on the mission trying to get it out to
everybody that we are able to do so much
more and uh,
you know,
it's all natural what we do.
So there is no money attached to it and
uh,
it's a,
it's a struggle to get it out there,
but we get more and more scientific
evidence a piling up.
And I'm here to present new insight.
Well,
I think you're winning a struggle for
sure because I hear about you all the
time.
I hear about you all the time for people
that have heard about you from my
podcast,
when people that say,
do you know this guy?
And I say,
yeah,
he's been on my podcast.
I know.
So the message is getting out 100
percent.
Wow.
That's a bio parameter for me.
Thanks for sharing that.
I will take it though,
don't you?
Oh yeah.
At this morning I was talking to Tony
Robins.
Oh Shit.
And he wants to cooperate on that shit.
Yeah.
And uh,
and now I'm Joe with Joe again.
I mean those are big names and uh,
I to listen to Tony Robbins tapes when I
was 20,
20 or 21 when I was a struggling standup
comedian.
He used to listen to is what was it
called?
Unlimited power.
Is that what it was?
Was an audio cassette and I listened to
it.
One was old school walkman thing.
Big chunky things.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And uh,
yeah,
he's got to his goal charity to get 100
million meals together this year and I'm
going to help them.
That's great.
What is he doing to that?
Just raising money and awareness,
raising money and to buy,
give a billionaire some very powerful
people who are very good insights in
their own stressful lives.
And uh,
I'm in there to teach them how to handle
stress hormone at the deepest in the
brain as in the,
in the body.
Beautiful.
You know,
I had a friend of mine who was trying to
do a parody on Tony Robbins,
so he went and researched him and he was
going to listen to some of his
recordings and listen to some of his
speeches.
And his goal was to find what's stupid
about it.
And then he started going like,
God damn,
this guy is honest.
And that was it.
Calvin,
do you remember who it was?
They were talking about it in here.
I believe it was calvin.
I think he was researching him for
something that he was doing.
And then along the way started realizing
like,
this guy's fucking legit,
but he's one of the rare ones,
like almost everyone.
That's like a professional motivator.
Then you go behind and go,
okay,
well what do you do?
You know,
like what do you do?
You just motivate people.
Have you had done anything?
Like you're telling people they can go
do things,
but what the fuck have you done?
What have you done sir?
And most of them,
they don't do shit.
They just get together with big
seminars.
They tell people they can do it,
you can do it.
Like fuck,
I can do it now.
But you never go,
hey man,
what have you done?
You on the other hand,
yeah,
you've done a lot of shit.
So it's one thing when people say,
well that,
that ice man Hoff Guy,
is he legit?
I'm like,
bitch,
do you have wikipedia?
Do you google?
Well we have the live and uh,
coming,
uh,
January,
we're going to do Kilimanjaro.
Yeah,
man,
you already offered that optimum shoot.
You shoot going to Kilimanjaro.
Hey man,
kill a man.
Know
anyone from afar,
from Los Angeles while watching
television,
I'll be live tweeting it
right on.
Right now we're doing a scientific
research and show that the rat cell
generation can be accelerated if it is
so in those circumstances than signs has
to update the circumstances where their
cells can be regenerated is like in 24
hours,
the body is not able to adapt to the
circumstances where there is a lack of
oxygen is half the oxygen nonetheless.
And we go into the altitude on
Kilimanjaro is a six,
like 20,000 feet at the top,
so to say 15,000 feet.
The acclimatization,
the adaptation is not as fast in human
bodies.
Now we found his breathing techniques
and using the mind and that enabled us
to accelerate that,
what they thought,
what signs is thinking that,
uh,
that it is arranged.
I'll autonomously so outside of our will
and we cannot interfere.
We cannot intervene now.
So we will show that with like 30 people
by the way,
past January I did it with a person 76
years old without a prior mountaineering
experience.
And he did it in 44 hours.
Don't 76,
uh,
I mean a,
that's a robust 76
year old,
but he was a good guy that will burn
brightly for the last couple of days.
His old life is dead,
really transferred.
So,
um,
let me ask you this.
So the standard model of what someone
can do as far as how much red so red
blood cells they can generate is
observed and they thought that it was at
15,000 feet it became too difficult.
But you've shown that with your
exercises and when your deep breathing
techniques that you can actually
accelerate red blood cell count on
consciously or at least not consciously
with your,
your through conscious action,
conscious action using the breath,
but what techniques are you using the
same what we did last time,
but then adapt it to while you are
walking and when a first sign of ams,
lack of oxygen into hat means headache,
a Mss,
acute mountain sickness and the first
sinus headache and that means a lack of
oxygen inside the brain.
Normally we are not able to get oxygen
then at that moment,
inside the brain to equal the violence
that violence,
the lack of oxygen.
And uh,
I've learned to just to do that.
So we tackled the problem and keep on
able to perform in the extreme
conditions even so through this
technique of taking these enormous deep
breaths,
letting some of it out and then trying
to refill and then letting some of it
out,
trying to refill,
letting some of it out.
And then you're forcing your body to
your forcing your lungs to constantly
carry air.
Yes.
Uh,
uh,
that it is,
we use the youngsters to passage way,
but it gets into the lymphatic system.
It gets into the tissue.
You know,
what we just found with the university
and in Germany they found out that the
devices that showed that we have 100
percent blood saturation,
oxygen in the blood is not 100 percent.
We go more.
They found it out for the thought was
100 percent blood saturation.
There's actually a higher level above
that.
Yes.
And that's what I always sad,
but now it says it's like proven.
So what they thought was 100 percent
blood saturation was just based on what
people normally do with no extra
techniques involved.
Is that what it is?
Absolutely.
Based on that they made devices and then
a 100 percent saturation in the blood is
100 percent and then you should be like
sane.
But now we've got this professor,
a biochemical professor.
Uh,
uh,
whatever his name,
Mr. Ms Dot Keith.
Doesn't matter.
Professor miscut at East.
Given the name.
Fuck it.
Yeah.
Like mosquito.
What a name.
A professor.
Yeah.
A professor,
fly professor mosquito,
this biochemical professor and he
telled,
uh,
looking at the results,
what you have produced with the
university regarding to the immune
system and influencing intuity
autonomous nervous system.
We can say,
uh,
you guys have found a way to tap into
the tissue,
into the lymphatic system and take away
the acidity over there.
And uh,
and the storage capacity of the
lymphatic system at that deeper level
than the blood is actually a storage
capacity to have chemistry.
Uh,
uh,
which is wrong as taught up over there
so it doesn't mess with a rest of the
physiology to maintain functionality.
So,
but in time you got to deal with it.
It's like garbage and at garbage we
could not tap into that.
And I'm so confused.
So what is that garbage?
The garbage is a wrong chemistry.
You like be a,
uh,
an acidic state of chemistry in the
lymphatic system as well.
Do they,
do they know what that.
I mean,
have they isolated that as is on an
actual compound?
Can I tell you what it is that they are
monitoring?
Yes.
It's actually a,
that acidity chronically,
they're not being dealt with.
This professor,
my biomedical professor tells us that a
95 percent of the auto immune diseases,
of course,
because of it,
so 95 percent of autoimmune diseases are
caused by some sort of acidity,
long term,
a long time presence of acidity not
being dealt with.
We'll deal with you in the end and
deregulate,
say the chemistry in the rest of the
body.
The biochemical processes actually does
quite logic,
logical,
but we.
And he knew he knew that,
but then we came up with this.
What is the cause of this acidity?
Is it diabetes?
Is a stress based?
Is it all the above?
Yes.
Anything that is stress too much we can
handle.
So Diet like inflammation,
stress as far as pressure,
life,
any stress we are not able to deal with
will be translated into chemistry.
And as you are not dealing with it,
it will be stored.
That might stop you right here because
for a lot of people that are listening
to this,
like,
what the fuck is Joe Rogan doing on this
podcast?
What the hell does about you are very
unique in that your claims are
incredibly unusual but substantiated by
science and this is not,
um,
is not woo science that this is real
legitimate researchers have they
injected you with what was it they
injected you with,
with an ICO,
live bacteria and endotoxemia and
endotoxin.
And then they monitored your immune
system and saw that you could actively
force your immune system to fight off
this injection.
Very specifically within a quarter of
our.
And this is something they did not think
was possible until you perform this.
Exactly.
They saw that I was influencing intuity,
so-called autonomous nervous system.
And then for also for people that did
not hear the first podcast you have
achieved.
I believe it's correct if I'm wrong.
20 six world records,
six,
including you have the longest time of
holding your breath and swimming under a
under ice ocean.
Nice too,
right?
Yeah.
So.
Oh Shit.
This is fucking incredibly cold water.
We're saltwater freezes over,
right?
Yes.
And you ran marathons basically in your
underwear with in his shorts and they
say beyond mit winter.
Yeah.
Beyond the desert.
Without drinking.
Yes.
No Mater of training because I don't
like running too much and I just do it.
Just do it.
It's like when your house is on fire,
you run fast,
right?
You don't need to train them.
Right.
And so I know how to tap into this
adrenaline,
a system,
the access it debris,
brainstem to reptilian mode.
I've learned that.
Well I have a lot of friends that have
followed your course.
Now my girlfriend denny,
apparently it was just with you this
past weekend in San Francisco,
denny provost,
he's a Brazilian jujitsu world champion,
or a good friend of mine and a really
interesting guy.
He loves your stuff.
And uh,
he's,
he's fascinated by it.
I know a lot of other people that are
fascinated by too,
a lot of people that I know that it
taking your course and trying your stuff
since the last time you were on.
So anybody who's listened to this
podcast for the first time,
you might want to go back and listen to
the first one and we go into great
detail about all the different
accomplishments that you've made with
your method,
the Wim Hof breathing method.
Um,
so in case you're listening to this for
the first time,
you're like,
why the fuck is this?
You know,
that's that it is again,
legit.
It's a legit Alegent,
uh,
and a legit.
And yeah,
we are legends.
Yes,
a legendary because we go pause,
perceive limits.
We go past the fear and what we perceive
as being possible.
We go past that because we pioneered,
we go past.
I would feel created by our
conditioning,
whatever we think is possible,
and we do not dare to go past that.
Well,
it's funny,
the.
I'm sorry I didn't ever really do,
but it's funny that your teammate was
Anthony Robbins because you hear the
Anthony Robbins.
Anthony Robbins loves to do those,
uh,
walking on fire things.
But uh,
lately it's been causing problems
because people pause in the middle and
take selfies and then they want to burn
their feet.
Silly
people.
So silly.
But uh,
we had Michael Shermer on who's a noted
skeptic and very,
very intelligent man.
And he explained what what it is,
is that,
you know,
the coals are very poor conductor of
heat.
That's why you don't cook right on
coals.
You use metal.
Metal's a great conductor of heat,
but the metal over the coals,
the metal gets heated up by the Kohl's.
And that sears your food.
You don't cook on Kohl's themselves
because it doesn't really transmit heat
that well.
That's why you can,
for 10 seconds or so,
you can walk over and real quick and you
don't really get that burned unless you
pause for selfies.
Yes,
yes,
uh,
I mean I go back to nature and then you
see before we wore his shoes actually
ridiculous things,
but we invented them and now we think
with a shiny shoes we have so much more
beautiful.
Right?
But shoes do look good though.
Choose to and they're colorful shoes and
all that.
Very nice but sometimes be more over
because of all these devices,
radiation,
we get to,
into the nervous system and we charged
with negative ions and for that,
you know,
any electricity you need to ground if
you've got big charts,
so it accumulate in the body and
therefore I suggest people walk
sometimes just inside of nature now the
all day,
but the release,
those negative ions are going to write
something down because I keep forgetting
it.
Is that true though,
like as far as a negative ions and doing
things to your body,
have they ever found any correlation
between the use of electronics and
negative aspects?
I just feel to you.
You think so?
I always go by my intuition.
I thinks at teacher won't approve it,
but I feel a lot better doing this.
I'm going to do to Kilimanjaro by the
way,
on a bad foot.
Oh yeah.
Man likes a challenge.
I have a friend of mine who went to
Bolivia.
He filmed,
he has a television show called
mediator.
His name is Stephen [inaudible].
He's a professional hunter and he went
to Bolivia and he lived with the Toumani
for a couple weeks and he brought them
shoes like,
hey,
you know,
try these shoes on that.
They didn't want to have nothing to do
with those shoes,
like stupid things out of here because
those people walk barefoot everywhere
and their feet.
He said their feet don't look at
anybody's feet.
He's like,
they're all splayed out like their toes
are splayed out and there's like a
thick,
thick padding underneath.
You know,
where they're basically have their own
shoes,
like the calluses and the bottom of
their feet.
Act as shoes.
That doesn't sound too attractive for me
to.
To have to attract abby,
to have feed like a heart and know what
I do is using my mind.
So you don't want to have callouses on
the bottom of your feet.
From what?
I got very soft baby feet.
So you really.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
My wife always does a self defeating
man.
So you are going to do this barefoot.
Are you gonna wear shoes at least?
No,
no,
no.
Not paying like that.
Your colleges to go once again,
mind over matter.
Well,
what about frostbite?
And I did the half marathon,
barefoot.
You did beyond the Polish circles in
temperatures even far more below than
the Kilimanjaro is.
Is it?
Do you think that's possible?
There's any benefit from the fact that
you're walking so much or running and
then your body is heating up and maybe
that has a positive effect on your skin.
Um,
the thing is I'm very able to,
uh,
to go away and to tap into the hormonal
system creating adrenaline.
You know,
this fact where people are sometimes
refer to,
they lift up and mother because the
child is underneath that actually is the
mind staring directly into the reptilian
mode.
The reptilian brain,
which is the primitive brain and that
you have direct access to pure
adrenaline,
makes you able to do almost
inconceivable a feet and accomplish it.
Only one tear right trigger.
Now,
because I have been so much into the
cold,
cold is cold,
is a real force impact upon you,
so you need to learn how to connect
within with your mind and you're
breathing into the brainstem,
into this adrenaline,
to withstand this force.
The cold impact.
I've learned it so you're tapping in
your brain,
you're causing your body to produce more
adrenaline and you're focusing on the
areas of your body that are contacting
the snow,
like you're focusing on the bottom of
your feet.
Yes,
yes.
And it works.
You know,
I'm still able to look around now it's
the sunset or the sunrise and and be.
So there is a margin even there,
right?
We just need to go back to belief and
unbelief.
There in means the neurotransmitters and
the neurons.
Those are signals and say churches.
So if you charge a,
a buddy,
then if you're able to influence up to
DNA level,
and we have proven this already,
but the aisle six enter location
connected to safe inflammation,
we could not find it off,
we could not suppressed decide to cast
the flammatory markers and we showed
very effectively not me,
only a whole group of persons which are
trained just four days
to be able to go into the DNA and create
the right chemistry consciously by
breathing and using the mind to fend off
flammatory markers a caused by,
say a bacteria inside.
So we are actually able to tap into the
deepest of ours,
create a,
have control over adrenaline's trestle
and go up to not only in the deepest
part of the brain but also in the DNA.
And um,
I,
I got interesting thing.
So let me ask you this.
The last time I believe you,
you've got a pile of notes.
What is it about breathing?
What is it about breathing or his
breathing?
Just one component of this.
Is it breathing and also focusing on
what you're trying to accomplish?
Yeah,
focus absolutely works.
Let me explain a little about,
uh,
about breathing.
Breathing is chemistry.
Oxygen has chemistry in the body,
so if y'all are able to access,
energize the cells more than we do
normally because we talked about the
lymphatic system and the tissue,
and actually the body's able to store up
more oxygen than the 100 percent.
We presumed a,
uh,
possible.
Scientifically,
we are able to store up more oxygen.
So Eva breathing technique,
whatever breathing technique is able to
store up more oxygen in the south,
that means go into the tissue going into
the lymphatic system.
Then suddenly the,
Eh,
the chemistry becomes alkaline.
The asset gets out of the body at will,
and then the mind,
the mind is positive,
a little electrical charges,
neurotransmitters,
and they are suddenly able to connect in
a buddy and you enabling you to have
control,
direct all the systems in the body.
That's the way nature Amanda to be.
So the mind a mind is conditioned to be
effective in the body is making the
body,
uh,
by breath,
right,
breathing profound breathing in an
alkaline state.
Then these electrical signals are able
to travel through out and the way nature
meant it to be is that we are able to
direct any part of the body,
so the immune system,
endocrine system,
the lymphatic system,
vasculars older systems where we told a
little bit last time,
but I got more direct evidence now and
right now we are working with the
universities on the brain and say
emotional reactivity and they see
incredible things that we actually are
able to get into those places where
emotion exists and we think emotion.
Where is it,
where is it,
but at this translated also as something
chemical so they can measure motion and
the chemical form.
Yes.
What are they?
What are they measuring it?
They they go into say a,
the hypothalamus,
hypothalamus,
hippocampus,
Amygdala.
Those are the places where this
chemistry is going on and we had no way
to get into that.
Now,
if you are able to access those parts
and to pressurize with breathing
techniques into those parts,
then suddenly you feel you begin to cry.
Why?
Because the chemistry is changing.
You are dealing with the chemistry which
was stored up because she couldn't work
it up before and now you're able to tap
in there,
change the chemistry,
and that that's the function.
Uh,
you are not able to deal with it now.
So later when you have peace and you are
a somewhere no,
not stressful,
then work on it and breathing does it.
It brought into it positively influences
the chemistry in the,
in the depth of the brain.
You know,
what happens?
You create 25 percent more blood flow
and blood flow is with oxygen through,
through your breathing.
Yes.
Well,
it makes sense because your blood is
being.
It's carrying oxygen,
right?
So the more oxygen you provide your
blood and you are definitely providing
it more with these big long,
deep breaths and these techniques that
you,
that you pursue.
Yes,
manipulating the spine,
the central nervous system up to the
tunnel of the light or the brain.
Stem is a top.
So if your pressure rise after inhaling,
exhaling like we did last time,
you did about three minutes,
almost a without in the lungs.
Very good.
First round is very promising for the
next rounds because you get more and
more oxygen,
it only to show that you are able to
store up oxygen far more than you ever
used before,
so in case when you need it to regulate
the chemistry inside the body,
then it needs oxygen.
Then you we are all able with these
breathing exercises to get it anywhere
where the chemistry is messed up and a
chemistry messed up,
we'll send off a signal,
but we are not emotionally not listening
because we get a worries and we need to
do the deadline and this and that so we
are not a chemistry stays over there and
will deregulate the system and then we
become sick and we don't know what's
happening.
We go to the doctor and a psychiatrist
because we become depressed and all,
but we are very able to get into any
place in the body and in this case,
the brain where we do all these studies
now with the university.
They say cognitive therapy just talking
to each other in the psychology and
psychotherapy.
That's not enough.
That was a conference with 200 experts
and they did this breathing and then
they say,
oh,
wow,
yeah,
talking a only as not enough,
but if you do this breathing,
then you really get into the brain.
Now suddenly you get a sense of control
because you're creating this extra
circulation of blood,
yes to together with oxygen,
making it alkaline.
Then suddenly the blockage is created
because of wrong chemistry because of
trauma or uh,
uh,
anxiety or grief.
Then suddenly that chemistry is being
dealt with and you get balanced.
[inaudible] simple,
and we keep it simple.
Uh,
and,
and try to get this web of our thoughts
thinking of so many difficulties and
complications.
What is emotion?
What is fair?
What is PTSD?
What is trauma?
What is depression?
We don't know where it is in the brain.
Just get all the brain full of oxygen,
get get to alkalinity up and you are
able to steer by going through the
spine,
up in your head and do it all.
Is that.
Why do you believe?
Is that why some studies have shown that
rigorous exercise,
particularly cardio like running a
elliptical machines,
things along those lines are just as
good for depression as medication?
Absolutely.
It,
it's dealing with the oxygen tension is
forcing when you think those giant deep
breaths you take when you're jogging or
something.
Yes,
I do.
When you do those things to you actually
create the body to be effective with the
oxygen,
then suddenly different mechanisms are
at work.
Uh,
more oxygen is coming in and the
chemistry is balancing out a depression
is caused by a wrong chemistry.
Creating inflammation.
I,
you know,
I'm a regular exerciser,
but sometimes I just get real busy and
I,
I take a couple of days off and
sometimes I take couple of days off and
I just don't feel right.
Maybe.
I mean I'm not a self indulgent person,
but sometimes I'll just feel like,
ah,
God,
I just feel kind of shitty today or
whatever.
And then I forced myself to exercise.
I go,
look,
I'm going to get up an hour early or I
want to do whatever I have to do and I'm
going to,
you know,
before I go to bed,
whatever it is,
I'm going to make sure that the day will
not end until I exercise and when I do
all that goes away,
the feelings go away.
It's like have a new brain.
It's like I leave there,
I'm smiling and laughing,
you know,
it seems like everything is just
beautiful again and that's you and it's.
And I'm the same person,
but it's also like my life has the same.
Not that my life is bad in way.
My life is fantastic.
It's not,
it's all great stuff,
but just being a person sometimes being
a person is overwhelming.
You're tired,
you know you're,
you have a lot of obligations,
there's a lot on your plate.
There's a lot of things going on and
sometimes it's overwhelming.
Sometimes you just feel down,
you know,
and I have a good life.
It's a very fun life.
If I didn't have a fun life and that
happened,
it would just be compounding all the
other issues that I have now.
Tack on that if I was overweight tack on
that if I was on hooked on pills or I
was an alcoholic or cigarette smoking or
one of the other things that are really
terrible for you that so many people
suffer from,
if all those things you don't think,
uh,
I think there's so many people that
think of depression or bad states of
mind as being just something that you
are a hand that you're dealt and it's.
I don't,
I don't necessarily think it's the case
with everybody because I don't know how
everybody's mind works,
but I know certainly from my mind I can
absolutely regulate those ups and downs
based on rigorous exercise.
And it doesn't have to be lifting
weights or crossfit or Jujitsu or
anything crazy.
Just go walk up a hill,
just go hike,
just go,
hike,
go hike.
You take those big deep breaths.
You get to the top of that hill.
You fucking feel great.
Yeah,
very good.
So,
uh,
I,
I can do that too.
You know,
you could do it,
you do it in your underwear.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No,
Go to the experiment and show that it is
all possible.
Even in the most extreme conditions.
Now I'm at the knocking at the door,
uh,
of science and I feel I'm able to help.
Well,
science very much interested in what
you're doing.
Yes they do.
The scientific community embraced this,
but I feel,
hey man,
I'm able actually to help a human men
card.
Well,
it's so extraordinary that one person
has this kind of influenced.
I mean,
I hope you realize what a service you're
providing to people because you're
bringing,
bringing awareness.
Well thank you,
but I'm doing is just talking to someone
who's awesome,
but this,
this thing that you've done,
you would think that other people would
have figured it out and that's what I
find most fascinating about you.
I would have thought that last time you
were here.
I mean,
I just,
it's hard to believe there are so few
people that have done what you've done
or figured out what you've,
what you figured out,
and then even more unusual,
what you've done is you've gone to
scientists and you said,
hey,
I think I'm onto something.
Please study me.
Like,
please study what I'm doing.
And you got people to listen to you by
accomplishing all these incredible
feats.
They go,
well,
this guy,
obviously he's doing something.
I mean,
who the fucking swim 100 yards under
frozen ice in one breath.
Who the fuck is running marathons
barefoot above the polar circle?
All this shit that you're doing it,
it,
it's,
it's wonderful.
It's forcing people to acknowledge the
fact that something extraordinary is
going on.
So it is.
And you know,
we got big problems and issues with
people with PTSD,
depression,
trauma,
fear,
anxiety in general.
It's all stress,
stress hormone.
And now using the,
uh,
developing a method and finding it out
because I
was in this quest to go deeper within
myself,
finding,
uh,
the,
the cold as the right teacher to bring
me into the depth of my physiology.
Finally finding a way,
the way nature meant me to be,
to feel strong and in control of myself.
I brought this now,
Eh,
to side.
And now it is a matter of time that we
will resolve what we have lost the
connection with the depth of ourselves.
And that means for people maybe not for
you,
because you are able to handle your mood
and your physical strength and your
health.
That's good.
But for those who have ptsd,
trauma,
anxiety,
fear,
depression,
our immune diseases,
cancer,
all these things I think nature knows.
And I found these keys in a nature.
I just bring it to the science and we
forgot about the nature.
And this is where I wear a couple of
note.
And,
uh,
I think,
you know,
if we are able not only to show that the
autonomous nervous system,
the hormonal system,
the immune system can be influenced
deeply,
that means hormone or system that is the
Melatonin,
Serotonin and dopamine and any feel good
hormone within us and the ability to tap
into that system and create those
hormones when necessary.
When you feel bad,
you just go get a shot naturally by
breathing unbelieving,
have the right hormones and you feel
great.
Okay?
And then you got the strength,
which is also based on hormones,
hormonal,
uh,
secretions like adrenaline,
epinephrine,
cortisol,
a dose,
and we show people lying in bed as I
taught last.
That tap embed,
embed,
producing more adrenaline controlled
stress or more than somebody going into
a inferior,
going into its first banking job.
That means controlled stress hormone,
adrenaline,
which is controlled.
Stress Hormone works like Madison.
And either it brings you back to the way
nature made us most effective in
situations of danger.
That could be cold,
the extreme cold heat.
It could be being credited by the light
control,
like a werewolf or.
Yes.
Yeah.
The real and
I think in society moves even bigger
than the one I saw you.
What do you think is a big shocks you
meet?
You use an analogy,
obviously you don't think that people
really turned to wolves.
He thinks,
no,
not really.
Not really.
Only in Hollywood and a lie can tropes
and old.
Very nice,
very nice,
very nice.
I just,
it a beautiful,
a beautiful,
beautiful piece of art and that,
you know,
that's the strength part and that you
get to,
uh,
the health part,
that immune system and all its layers.
So let me ask you this,
because adrenaline with fighting,
uh,
is,
is considered to be a very dangerous
thing to,
to manage because there's a thing called
the adrenaline dump that happens to a
lot of fighters.
So they get so worked up,
they're so jazzed up before a fight and
then they're in the fight and then
somewhere around the first round the
adrenaline goes away and they have this
dump and they get exhausted.
Uh,
that's,
that's very interesting.
It's called adrenaline dump and it
happens,
but I mean they're under extreme
stressful situations in guys gas.
How'd they get very tired very quickly
and a lot of them talk about it.
I couldn't believe how tired I got and
it's attributed to adrenaline.
Yes,
but that then is no control over the
adrenaline,
so bright.
So they allow it to run away from them.
It's like that old expression.
Do you remember the.
There was a very famous custom motto.
Expression customer was the guy who
trained Mike Tyson.
He said,
fire can be your friend or it can be
your enemy can cook your food or it can
burn your house down.
It depends on how you control it.
It's all very interesting to defining
modus of ours,
which is related to the fight mode is
fight,
flight food,
priests and fuck,
that's the brainstem.
Yes.
It's all the same energy.
It's oldest.
Hey,
managing.
Yeah.
Procreation.
Protect your children.
Food.
Primal,
primal.
The primal forces are directly related
to adrenaline and we lost a control
there over because we lost the deeper
connection with,
uh,
with that system within our brain,
the brainstem.
And therefore we do not know how to
handle danger anymore as such,
danger is not only cold and a heat and
oxygen deprivation as a,
uh,
situations like Mount Everest or
something,
but also daily stress.
It's also things seeing things that
carry with them extreme consequences or
you get nervous and you get freaked out.
Yeah,
and I think that's for people that
aren't in situations that are very
stressful,
very often
it becomes a huge issue and they
oftentimes can't control their
adrenaline.
They can't control their anxiety,
they can't control that.
Even their own thoughts.
They get tunnel vision.
It's like they're in an elevator as the
doors are closing shot and they can't
see.
You literally see it in fights.
You see people panic and that panic does
not allow them to be present,
which does not allow them to perform at
their very best.
And they're almost,
they're almost always severely
diminished because of that adrenaline or
because of that panic,
I should say,
not necessarily the adrenaline,
but the,
the loss of management,
loss of loss of your ability to be
sovereign.
You know,
you're not in control anymore.
You're being carried away by a wave of
fear.
Yes.
Now I ideal with her sports people.
He did a lot of work with allister over
me and many more,
many more.
And I'm uh,
in general when they do the breathing
exercises and the cold exposure,
deb has become just more energetic and
they have a lot more connection with
their own body,
the creating confidence within
themselves.
And then they are able to build up this
connection mind body and,
and uh,
they are cardio increases their
tranquility.
Well,
you had some great results with the
Alastar let me tell you that because he
was on a downward spiral
or you started working with us,
kind of come to Kilimanjaro to,
because I need to train them again.
I think he lost track a little bit on
the breathing exercises and he thought
he was already there.
I think that that's my opinion.
And I talked to,
uh,
will,
we will go to the Kilimanjaro.
I,
I will say,
listen,
here,
you have to breathe here.
You will understand the significance of
breeding and now to take a to lightly go
back into yourself and do not think you
are there,
be there and the mountain.
The mother nature will show you.
It's not me.
I just know to abide by the laws of
Mother Nature and that's why I do these
feet there and it makes me able to adapt
very rapidly to changes in like a cold
heat,
oxygen deprivation situations,
anything.
It's there and a mother nature will
teach them.
Why do you think that he stopped doing
it?
Like what?
What gives you that indication?
There's a certain moment people think I
control,
I can control it,
I can do it and I'm in a positive spiral
going up and it's all okay.
Then they leave this connection and they
fall back into old patterns.
The old neurology,
the old conditioning.
So they require daily practice until
it's really mastered.
So it takes how many years it takes to
condition your body.
A really to,
uh,
to become really so good to be in,
say,
k one.
And I'm a at the top.
It takes years to build that up.
But it's still there.
He will compete with people who also
conditioned their bodies,
so it's a eagle thing going up and what
makes the difference.
That's the connection of your mind with
your body,
of your brainstem,
with your conscious will and the body
controlling the adrenaline,
not only auto painter,
friend,
noradrenaline,
dopamine,
anything.
Now when you're watching someone like
alister fight and he just fought for the
UFC heavyweight title and came very
close to winning a couple of times in
that first round and wind up losing.
What makes you think that breathing
could have helped him in that?
Because he almost won the fight.
He almost knocked pay out.
He almost caught him in a guillotine
choke.
I mean,
and he had Steve Bay and a lot of
trouble on two separate occasions than
Steve Bay caught him and knocked him
out.
What makes you think that breathing
would have helped him?
Their breathing
brings in oxygen.
Oxygen makes buddy alkalotic the nervous
system that that is a nervous system,
goes better when it is alkaline.
The swiftness of neurotransmitters,
which is a neurotransmitter in the way
makes the body react like Bruce Lee
Taylor again,
say the word again,
I'll say till Hollinger as a teal
collide.
Acetylcholine.
Yes.
Okay.
And yes.
What I do all the time with people or
women who are not able to do pushups,
I make them do the breathing,
influence,
muscle tissue,
making it alkaline.
So the neurotransmitter,
the performance,
newer terms,
motors suddenly is able to keep on
because it's not becoming acidic.
When you say acidic and alkaline,
what are you measuring?
Are you measuring blood?
Are you measuring muscle,
muscle tissue?
How are they doing?
Uh,
you can,
uh,
but with a simple ph strip,
you can show yourself,
say before e five a,
and who's doing these tests as
scientists,
we're doing these tests.
You.
Yes,
that's what we,
we just completed the new studies were
two for 48 people and it showed that all
the people got to very,
very high alkaline levels in the blood,
like seven point eight.
What's normal at seven point three?
Seven.
Point four is natural.
And then you go all the way up to seven
point eight and then it comes back and
it stays over there for all the day long
and that's what you want.
But most of the People Are Acidic if you
pee on it.
And then you will see with a Ph strip,
yellow to blue and green in the middle.
And all these variations,
they say most of the people are just
yellow in the morning and they do the
breathing 20 minutes and they become
blue.
Boom.
And that's why you want to have it.
Because the neurotransmitters,
the electrical signals in the body,
they traveled a lot faster when it's
alkaline.
So you same punch will be faster if a
disease alkaline.
Then when Sam Seder.
And actually it's a logical,
if I'm going to train with us and become
a headache at a certain moment,
you know,
I get to my limit that I not a pointing
as fast.
Then when alkaline,
it's all in the muscle and we are able
to influence their right.
So,
um,
he,
he did,
he wasn't too much in the breathing
animal.
That was
a no,
I saw it.
I saw how you could tell,
I imagined before I was in his room and
uh,
we did,
I tested him,
hey,
how is your breathing and how is your
retention?
Like what you did two and a half minutes
to first round you remember that means
you store up oxygen in the body and
therefore you have no need for breathing
and you just measuring that.
So do you think any of them had to do
with the stress of fighting for the
first time title?
Not.
Well,
he was over over to to confident.
Really.
You think he was too confident?
Too confident.
Why do you say that now?
Because I saw her psych.
Yeah.
But it didn't seem that way to me as a,
as a trained observer,
I felt he was dealing with a lot of
anxiety because especially the way he
was fighting,
he was,
I mean he literally was running at
certain points and yeah,
that's how I saw.
I saw I was there.
Yeah,
I saw you there.
The ring.
I was somewhere on the stairs.
So I know,
I'm just saying like when I look at that
and I look at the way he was performing,
he wasn't performing the way he
performed against junior dos Santos.
Yes,
exactly.
Yeah.
And that's because,
and that's what I think with all the
respect for him.
I love him.
He's a good guy,
but he uh,
his mother nature knows better and I
know mother nature,
so I saw he needs to get back to this
breathing back thing,
making it alkaline daren and keeping it
on until the conditioning.
The old patterns go away.
So you think he got tired?
What do you think happened there?
Yes,
but what about him getting hit?
Because he got.
Yeah,
I mean he went for a.
anything you are not able to receive
blows as,
as good as a chemistry,
which is low in Ph level is if you are
acidic that then you are.
I understand that to receive the steeper
meal check,
the UFC heavyweight champion is 250
pounds of meat.
He's a scary dude and he hits very hard
and he's very accurate and there's not a
whole lot of people that he punches in
the face that don't get knocked out and
the way he was hitting allister,
I have a hard time believing that
anything would have saved him,
whether it's breathing or anything.
He was getting cracked.
Again,
one of the best fighters in the world.
Yes,
of course.
That's good.
But I'm not into a increase in the
performance of any sports when I do that
at the side,
but I want to draw to your attention for
people who are suffering in the world.
No,
I understand that.
But whatever I am,
I just,
I'm talking about this moment in
specifically.
Why did you think that his lack of
breathing or whatever it had an effect
on it.
Did you feel like he got tired too
quickly?
Did you notice him diminishing his
energy levels?
Dropping?
Like what?
What did you seen that made you believe
that he was not doing the breathing
practice?
It's not only have that day,
uh,
[inaudible],
it's a whole process,
right?
So if y'all are at a top like that at
the most of,
uh,
they're fighting a level to have this
world,
then you got to work your body,
you got to condition your body and that
you do with the ride breathing exercises
along with the fighting and the air
conditioning and the muscle training at
all.
And if it is not there that you can have
the muscles of the world,
but very soon you will be exhausted.
Now when you work with a guy like
alister,
with all due respect to him and to you,
he's been knocked out four times in the
UFC alone and he's been knocked out many
times outside of the UFC.
Do you have any concern about the amount
of damage that he's taking and do you
think that in any way,
this kind of training and the breathing
method could in some way help mitigate
some of that damage he's taking?
Absolutely,
yes.
Yes.
And um,
I will say about him,
he will come back.
It will get a very good lesson though
for my mother nature and me and Darragh
is no,
you cannot speculate about mother
nature.
You just got to perform the right way.
What do you mean by the 24 hours getting
up a kid of Magento,
that beans with his weight and getting
out there,
that means breathing,
really breathing,
really getting into and using your mind
and focus.
Totally not thinking that you are able
to do it,
but doing it.
One thing that does happen to fighters
and it happens inevitably in a fighter's
career,
if they've taken a lot of fights where
they were real wars,
is they lose their ability to take a
punch.
It's a physiological response.
The brain has to.
The amount of punishment that you've
been taking and it knows the punishments
coming and it shuts off prematurely,
shuts off much quicker than it did when
you were younger and in the fight game,
they call it getting Chiney or his chin
is gone.
You know where you take a shot and you
can see that you just can't take it
anymore,
and doctors take that almost universally
as a sign.
They should probably start thinking
about hanging it up.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I see that at all in him and you.
Are you concerned about that at all?
I will say that did a January.
So you'll see it once you make it a,
but that's,
it doesn't have anything to do with
physical condition.
It has more to do with punishment.
Has More to do with getting hit.
I'm not so much into fighting and oldest
toll information.
I just know how nature works and I will
test them.
I will see it.
I will observe and get my objective.
I will try to help him and I get my
objective opinion.
Uh,
they're in and that's what I'm going to
do.
I'm going to take a,
by the way,
Aalto a high performance,
uh,
extreme athlete as well,
up on the mountain,
but also people with conditions and
that's actually even more interesting.
Like what kinds of conditions like
Crohn's disease and Roma to weed to
thrive.
This asthma and they will make it in 24
hours as well,
just because of this breathing.
People with rheumatoid arthritis,
you can take them up.
Mount Kilimanjaro already did I already
did?
Yes.
And they do oldest program all the time
and they have zero flammatory markers
left in the body.
So they controlled a or a condition,
arthritis,
crones disease.
I'll take immune diseases complete.
And how severe is their arthritis?
Because people that are like really
crippled and they can't walk very well.
You've done that with them and with
papers it up to a certain level.
I mean if you can't walk anymore,
right?
How do you of Magento.
Right.
But if you can barely walk or what?
If you can walk,
we'll walk slow or what if you walk when
you walk in pain?
Hey,
yes.
I'm into scientific research because I
want to help humanity direct and I know
what we are able to tap into the systems
and begin to heal first before we go
into say feats like that.
So you work with these people that have
arthritis or Crohn's disease right now
to strengthen their immune system,
scientific research or their
inflammation first year.
And how much time do you spend with them
before you take them to something like
extreme environment?
Like Kilimanjaro I got now my
instructors ever.
We were.
So first I teach them in
a session.
How many instructors?
Yeah.
Now what,
how many is it?
A $200.
200.
Wow.
All over the world.
Uh,
uh,
mostly in the Netherlands now.
But now America is beginning to do the
basic course,
an advanced module.
And then we have the instructors wick
and it goes up to a bachelor level,
eh?
The books are in the university.
It's real late at all and scientifically
endorsed.
And there it is.
It works and it works with us for those
people.
And we still got to find out tomorrow
par example,
I got a,
uh,
scientific,
sort of lecture together with Professor
Huberman from Stanford University in
front of Ideo and Ideo.
There comes a guy who is the google
healthcare,
a hat of the doll,
and he was the former man in charge of
the health care in America.
In us.
I mean big people and it's not for
nothing.
They see it works.
It doesn't work only for say people with
arthritis,
but also with depression is how much
people feel better.
Yes.
Yes,
yes.
Preventative,
uh,
increasing quality of life.
Yes sir.
Yes sir,
and that is only because of a simple
principle out of nature.
Go back to mother nature inside,
go back into the depth of your own
physiology and know that it is dire.
You are able to awaken that and get it
into your control,
preventing you from disease,
from depression or becoming happy,
healthy,
so essentially it's in some ways tapping
into the same force that creates the
placebo effect because there is an
effect when your mind thinks that it has
a drug that's going to heal it,
even if it's a sugar pill.
You see a visible improvement on many
people because of that belief,
your belief system plus the oxygen plus
the deep breathing exercise and the
increasing blood flow to the brain.
It has all these positive and then at
the Colt trains,
gradual cold exposure trains their
transportation system.
Seventy 5,000 miles of capillaries,
arteries and veins within us.
They transport oxygen.
There are in a primitive muscles and
reflexes and when they are stimulated by
cold showers,
just cold showers,
then the heart rate is going down and
the transportation of oxygen suddenly is
a lot better and it gets to the immune
cells.
Logically.
The immune cells,
we are more alert,
better fat at a date.
They recognize intruders who should not
be there and they.
They killed up there.
It's like cell death and they put a
specific hormone molecule on the cell
membrane and it's gone now.
How long has it been since the first
podcast?
We did.
Was it two years?
A year and a half or something like
that?
A year and a half.
Jamie will tell us.
October 2015.
Oh,
recently.
First.
Basically year.
One year,
yes.
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
So what?
What has happened in a year?
What new breakthroughs or what new,
what new evidence and have in that year.
The evidence is that people are
beginning to grasp the gravity of what I
found because two and a half years ago
I,
we had this publish it in one of the
best papers of the world,
the past papers to what proceedings of
National Academy of scientists,
which is highly repetitious,
reputed to scientific or a magazine.
It's like nature and United States and
if you come and get into there then it's
really solid,
so they took it up into the books,
designed at a university books full
chapter,
and that's not for nothing and that's
what the new information,
the new physicians and biologists need
to digest as being signs.
So it is science and it's two and a half
years ago that we approved the autonomic
nervous system up till death.
Never been proven in scientific history
to be influenced by humans now,
not little bit to be influenced.
Being able to be influenced big time
people,
enabling it within a quarter of our way
to tap into the specific immune system,
which normally takes five to seven days.
So that's a big finding.
I thought,
wow,
now the world is going to turn the other
way.
Now people are going to see.
We are able to do so much more with what
we've got already.
They are going to receive 10 Nobel
prizes,
you know,
something like that because it is
something like that.
Right?
But Eh,
it takes time.
It takes time.
So since last year I see more and more
and more people getting to this and
that's nice,
but I want scientific validation more
because apparently they do not really
grasp within the scientific community
the gravity of what we found.
It's historical.
It's not mine itself,
Mother Nature for don't you think?
It takes time for people and their
opinions to shift when it comes to
things along these lines.
Apparently that's the psychology of
people and I'm finding this out.
I got,
I got in the beginning,
very frustrated.
Now I begin to understand this is the
way it all comes top down and it takes
some time.
When Galileo found out that we are not
the center of
the universe,
but it is the sun and we are turning
around.
He was almost banned from the church and
almost sentenced to death as a heretic
or things like that,
you know,
and it was just as truthful a new way of
thinking.
Right.
Well apparently not experiencing that
kind of resistance.
Right.
While you were experiencing not really
seen universally praised.
Yes.
Yeah.
It's just a matter of acceptance,
meaning people actually practicing it.
That's the issue.
I think the consequences,
the positive consequences of practicing
this are enormous for every person into
and very accessible,
very effective,
very fast.
I use your method before I go on stage a
really?
Yes.
I started doing it.
I started doing it after our podcast
together.
I take these big giant deep breaths.
I let some out,
big giant deep breaths and I let them
out and I do it for several minutes
before my shows and I feel like I'm
high,
like I'm just filled with everything.
Like woo would just feel crazy pumped
up.
Good,
good,
good.
Does that enabled you to get a direct
access,
better access to your adrenaline?
Uh,
the hormonal system and gives me,
it mean that breeding in like that it
gives me energy,
it gives me,
it elevates me,
it feel,
it feel like it elevates my energy
levels.
Thanks for taking it on.
Thanks for having me last year this
year.
And I'm into ongoing research right now
with German,
you know,
what's happening and how we got to.
We found out first time in scientific
history now and not me,
the university doing this,
uh,
doing this,
say to.
I was worried that it got on the
machinery.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Thanks.
So for the first time in scientific
history,
they found out that hundred percent
saturation or oxygen in the blood is not
really 100 percent right.
But what I don't understand that there's
no nothing more than 100 percent.
Right?
So did they just not understand shit?
So they had,
they had a level that they thought was
100 percent and they said,
well,
nobody has ever reached a higher level
and this.
So this must be what 100 percent
saturation looks like.
Exactly.
So it's not that you got more than 100
percent saturation as you achieved
higher levels of saturation than they
thought possible.
Is that a better way of describing?
Exactly.
And they did it with a laser on the on
the chest and that you are able to
measure the mitochondrial oxygen
tension,
Mitochondria electrical factor,
a little factories in the cell,
the engines of the sale of the south,
they are able to receive more oxygen and
that's
very interesting and that's a great
finding.
I mean more than a hundred percent first
time in days three.
That's a great finding I think,
and it shows that we are able to have
more oxygen inside.
Suddenly we are able to get into the
cell influence energy and energy
production,
the ATP that those are molecules and if
it is an aerobic then it's like two
molecules are able to produce.
When it becomes Arabic,
then it's up to 38 molecules that can
produce,
that is energy and we are able to
produce more oxygen.
What happens,
what happens with a cell that is
deprived for 48 hours of 35 percent less
oxygen?
It becomes cancerous.
Real.
Yes sir.
And as simple as that,
have you ever worked with cancer
patients?
I want to now with the universities,
but it's very,
very difficult.
Complicated matter and everybody thinks
it's not able to,
uh,
be
questioned or a research imperative to
these people get medication because
their lives on the line.
They could die thousand dollar a year.
Those are good clients.
What's 200,000?
Oh,
the cancer patients.
So they,
you think that there's an issue where
they don't want to lose that money?
Right.
What do you think?
Well,
maybe,
but don't you think there's some
patients out there are some who have
autonomous control of the.
I got one.
I got one guy who just gave me a book.
Big Book.
What is his name?
I just gave the book to a professor and
he cured from terminal cancer.
I met him in 2007.
He had stage four cancer.
What kind of cancer?
Skin cancer,
which deteriorate all the,
all the skin.
And then you're gone.
You're not able to function and silver
and he wasn't stage four,
so almost a terminal and I met him in
2007 then and I told them,
listen,
what the science is telling you that is
not really what really is.
It is only what has been found up to
now.
So,
or I found that the autonomic nervous
system,
for example,
can be influenced the endocrine system,
the immune system.
What,
what else and what more don't yield,
don't yield,
get on and positive thinking they're in
a positive charges.
That's what,
but breathing and now it appears to be
that 48
hours,
35 percent less of oxygen NSL becomes a,
makes a cell cancers.
So what I told you just now that the
molecules we can influence that,
uh,
the,
the engines of the cell and make much
more,
uh,
much more molecules by implementing but
jet by breathing.
Good.
Do reading unbelieving.
Do you think that it would benefit
people that are already under cancer
treatment?
Like if they're already in therapy or
radiation,
you know,
the chemo actually works better if you
do the breathing techniques.
Why is that?
It goes more specifically into that
area.
Boom.
And Chemo is essentially poison,
right?
Yes,
it is.
And what I wear if I'm gonna drink here
by the way,
another little bit or it what would not
be bad.
Yeah.
My son is saying,
no,
don't do it in
listening.
I got some control.
Yeah.
I made him tell him to fuck off.
If it could do that.
Chairs sometimes.
Yo.
The story goes like this with my son.
I was in Africa and uh,
on the Kilimanjaro.
Then after I did a successful attempt in
a $28 and the insurance and everything
got to tell something about Scott County
to an investigative journalist who came
to get me a disguised as a guru and a
with lies and everything he disguised.
I know he wanted to do you say an
investigative journalist and
anthropologist and he came to Poland to
see who I am for real.
He,
he is into finding out how to uh,
the organ trafficking goes and these
gurus who will make people do things.
He thought you were one of those?
Yes.
Why?
Because he was paid to do,
to,
to get to me and investigate him,
but his attitude is the guy who was
publishing his books and he made a new
book her lately,
but he came to Poland and uh,
two days later he was doing the same
shit.
I'm doing that so much.
I didn't end up on the outside though.
We'll do see someone like you that makes
all these crazy claims and you know,
talks about love and breathing and go,
oh,
this guy's all about trying to fuck
everybody's wives and make a lot of
money.
No,
no,
no.
Just I'm very,
uh,
I know.
But that's,
that's.
Yes.
I know you were legitimate.
I know you are,
but there's a lot of people like you can
understand why he would touch a lot of
people who make these grand claims turn
out to be,
um,
you know,
there's a lot of people that can claim
miracle claims.
They usually crazy,
right?
Yes,
yes,
yes.
So I went with this investigative
journalist and he became a fool adept.
And did he give up the ghost?
Did he tell you what he's doing?
He totally,
totally took two days to disappear,
his distance and all,
and then he was also in his shorts on
bare barefoot in the snow.
Is that what are you doing there?
Just move it.
I can teach.
You can teach them.
Maybe not.
Maybe you can teach me to teach me.
Sometimes I think you can teach me some
techniques,
but I can teach you for sure.
Altos some techniques like standing for
two hours,
barefoot in the snow,
in your shorts and in the horse stance.
Yeah.
You're not going to teach me that.
No,
no.
Not doing that.
It could be.
I believe it can be done.
Yeah.
Look,
if I had to do it,
I felt like I feel like I could do it if
I had to do it.
Yes.
Would I do it?
I'm busy.
Yeah.
Were for two days your underwear wax on,
wax off,
laughing,
stuck.
But many people do this and they
suddenly see that they are capable of
doing so much more because they begin to
learn to control the acidity that what
becomes acidic in their bodies.
So the performance and for that I do
that.
So he did it and together with me last
January it was also on the Kilimanjaro.
You stay friends?
Yes.
He wrote a book that what doesn't kill
you?
It says it will come out next month or
something.
And it is about you.
It's mostly about what I do.
The method?
Yes.
Yeah.
And that I worked at [inaudible].
He's a,
he's a scientist and he is an
anthropologist but he is always trying
out the stuff he's writing about.
So we got into this and there's a very
nice book.
Maybe you shoot.
He,
he's got a teaser on is very nice,
but I'd love to have them on.
Hey,
Scott Carney.
Okay,
well let me know and we'll,
we'll talk after the show.
Let me know like when the book's going
to come out.
Yes and no,
I'll try it.
There is a teaser and you see it all.
Awesome.
I think it's very,
uh,
it's beautiful and it's very good for a
human for anybody to see.
And he lost weight very fast and it
could do now are 80 pushups without
breathing.
[inaudible] 80 pushups without
He was an intellectual list.
Yes.
He can hold his breath and do 80
pushups.
Yeah,
so I find that very hard to believe with
no air in the lungs,
by the way.
No.
What?
No air in the lungs.
No,
he goes,
really?
He goes down nowhere in the long blows
out of the air and then there's eight
zero pushups in a row.
Yes sir.
I call bullshit.
Yeah.
And I do it the ultimate it was this guy
look like,
Eh,
I don't know,
maybe as wide as the fucking savage,
just to be able to do 80 pushups,
periods,
control of oxygen.
You can do one pushup because you are
alkaline,
but if you are able to maintain the
alkalinity in the buddy,
hey,
there you go.
Is there a video?
This guy doing 80 push pushups with no
oxygen in his lungs.
I believe him.
I saw him do math at least 50 in my
time,
but he went off and I see too many
people,
but I see older people with roof with
arthritis who cannot do any push up and
I make them do 40 pushups in in one day.
Why?
Because we controlled the flammatory
markers in the blood,
suppressing them,
and suddenly they are able and with the
extra oxygen,
making it alkaline.
The muscle tissue keeps on throwing
these as a teal holiness the neuro
transmitter performance and they
surprised themselves,
astonished themselves,
but that just seems like a lot of
pushups do with no air in your lungs.
What does it say here?
I can do 80 pushups on a single breath
and I lost seven pounds of belly fat and
70 days,
motherfucker there.
You know,
I'm not an athlete.
I'm not exceptional.
Listen Bitch,
if you could do 80 pushups in a single
breath,
that's fucking exceptional.
I want to know what he's calling a
pushup if he's one of these
motherfuckers.
No,
no,
no doubt.
Yeah,
let.
Let.
Let him.
I want to see this.
I want to see you
then
I call bullshit.
Okay,
touch your chin,
chin,
go back up all the way up,
lock it out.
Yeah.
Then it takes about at least two minutes
to do that.
Then you asked him to,
uh,
to uh,
while you're exercising at least.
Right?
I think I couldn't do one.
I couldn't do that.
You can do that right now.
You do 80 pushups on a single breath.
You would know.
You think so?
I don't know.
Let's try it.
Why don't you try it and you to me too.
I know I can't do it.
I can't do 80 pushups on a single
breath.
I'll tell you right now.
I can't do it.
So wait.
Were we don't need to prove this now
while this thing is time.
Now's a good time.
But we will,
we will wait.
Well,
another thing,
actually I wanted to come back because
we do it.
I'm telling a story about my son.
Oh,
that's the old original step.
So the guy was trying to investigate
you.
He thought you were a fake gurus and we
did in 28 hours,
they kill him with our lives to January
insured.
And he did it too,
right?
So a very nice and all done,
but then later when we did it
accomplish,
I mean the biggest feat was the 76 year
old man doing the kingdom on channel 44
hours.
That's A.
Yeah,
it's unheard off.
And he did it anyway.
And
with them we are 26 other people,
men,
women,
old young.
We did.
It will,
how it's taken them 44 hours to do this
climb and timing to the top and.
Yeah.
But I mean like how many miles is it?
How many?
Seven miles in 40.
Four hours.
It's a lot of gold.
Went up hiking and extreme altitude,
right?
Yes.
Why don't you Google?
What's the world record pushups for a
single breath?
Turns out 60.
Hey,
if it is exactly that,
we got the new world record coming up.
So you were saying your son?
Yes.
Right.
So afterwards,
when we did it and accomplish it to last
January I went to is through to these
natural reserves and uh,
yeah.
You know,
you got the Serengeti Russia a no go on.
Goto a crater with the lions and
everything.
I do things with the Messiah.
He as well.
Can I ask you this?
Did you take malaria medication when you
went there?
No.
Will you,
were you there when the mosquitoes were
around show?
They always around.
He didn't worry about malaria?
No.
They cause inflammation,
so I think I'm able to deal with that,
so I take a little deal with malaria.
Absolutely.
Wow.
Yeah,
right.
Man,
I'm.
I'm open for any research and
investigation.
I believe in,
in,
in Mother Nature and Mother Nature came
to me and I got so much field work done.
I know all the tricks of Mother Nature
and what it does in the body and we
forgot about it because we never expose
ourselves in mother nature anymore.
We always take the choice of comfort,
right?
But we actually built to be stimulated
by wind,
cold heat,
pressure differences and all kinds of
things and that makes us strong.
It makes our immune system strong and
then bacteria,
viruses and back so suddenly have a lot
less chance to get in and do their
damage.
And at this it's a fact.
It's not me.
It's mother nature within us and that
control we lost because we lost the
connection and uh,
it's very important to bring that.
And I think malaria.
Yes,
we can now,
not only,
it's also in the books now in hey,
possibly a university books.
Possibly hope for people with HIV.
I have a friend,
my friend Justin Wren,
he does a lot of work with the pygmies.
He works with water four and he builds
wells in the Congo and he's had malaria
three times and when he gets it,
it's pretty bad and not only does he get
it,
but now because he's had it so many
times,
he gets it if he gets sick.
So when he's in America,
if he catches the flu or something like
that,
he also gets malaria.
It's happened.
Flammatory markers,
deregulation of the immune system that
you could help him.
Yes sir.
I need to.
I need to connect you to.
Absolutely.
Okay.
Before you leave,
I'm going to get you his information.
I'm swap information with you guys.
I think that'd be amazing if you could
actually help him because he's,
he's amazing.
He's done amazing,
amazing stuff.
I mean,
that guy spends months at a time.
Yeah,
I can't imagine he's a pioneer.
Oh Man.
He's going to feel like we began off.
Those are the people dose I man looking
for more to,
to do a valid per whatever we go for as
human mankind,
and to finally get into some love,
like a sharing and caring tribal.
So what happened when your son?
Yes.
So I went through this reserve,
big Serengeti,
and then you got these big elephants.
Luxor don't or Luxor don't.
Africana know big stuff.
I know.
Elephants,
eh?
They can go up to seven tons of meat.
So they.
I went to a lot of these big elephants
and I lifted up there till two in the
back and to see how big the asshole is.
Oh Wow.
I saw a lot of big hassles.
My son is still the and
I made the phone call.
It's all about fun because I love to
joke about.
He is to a very severe with me.
He's like,
he can be.
He said it's sitting there very to
inquiry,
but he can be like a wolf with her.
Her Dad.
No,
not yet.
I said I asked him to not talk during
the show and now you're egging them on
and you're forcing them to defend
themselves.
That's totally unfair.
An asshole.
It makes my business,
you know,
my mission and it makes it able to
happen in this world because I'm not of
this world.
I'm too much of nature.
I'm so naive.
But he is outlining everything with
websites of activity to people who are
not of this world.
I mean a lot of the modern world
electronics and that shit you just not
to.
Do you have a cell phone?
Yes.
Yeah,
Duh.
I lose them a lot.
And uh,
things like that.
But you know,
what happened with the cell phones a in
Finland,
lapland or [inaudible],
Alaska where they live,
uh,
in distance with each other.
Telepathy is.
And where there's no cell phones.
Yeah.
Where there's no cell phones.
But since the telephone came,
a introduce itself over there,
the people lost this ability.
What do you mean?
Like,
um,
what they knew every time one day a
neighbor is coming
that are already setting things up
without seeing it with the eyes and ears
and that's common.
What is that?
D Cell phones game and they take it over
and we have to learn that we all have
these not only physiological abilities
deeper but also in the mind a beautiful
things and we are having it taken over
by tech technical devices and all that.
But whereas the contact with our
conscious contact with our depth,
what is it?
And I'm going for it.
But is there any evidence these people
were really telepathic?
No,
it's anecdotal of course,
of course.
But people full of shit out there living
by themselves just doing weird shit to
themselves out there screaming.
No one answers.
Lone wolves howl.
There was a too old.
Yeah,
you gotta take that into account.
People are full of Shit.
You got.
There was an old television show on the
road.
Do you remember on the road with Charles
Kuralt?
Is that who it was?
There was a guy that used to have this
television shows way back in the day
before the Internet.
I remember he had this episode on
whether it was talking to this guy who
was a.
He was a trapper and he would live in
the Bush and Alaska and he would live
there and not talk to a single person
for months and months at a time,
and what he would say is that after a
while when he was out there by himself,
he would develop this very bizarre
feeling of telepathic,
of telepathy with animals and that he
could read animals minds.
You could almost predict their behavior
and movements and he was getting signals
from them that he couldn't describe and
when he would go back to the town,
when he would come back after six
months,
after a couple of hours or a day or so,
it would go away.
And it was like whatever.
That thing was interesting when he had
no contact with people and he swore by
it.
But again,
it could be a fucking crazy dude out
there.
You know,
the Muskrat's with a giant trap.
It's anecdotal.
We are social mammals,
mammalian behavior like families and
things like that,
but I've read that
I have found one thing that they're
pretty sure that people can tell and
that is hard.
It's very hard.
It was rupert sheldrake's podcast he was
talking about.
He was saying that one thing that they
have studied beyond statistical
probability,
it shows that when people are stared at,
like say if you,
if I turned my back and um,
you either would look down at your lap
or look at the back of my head that I
could tell or someone maybe some people
can tell whether or not you're looking
at them more than half the time.
They were more accurate than guessing.
And it was consistent.
It was pretty consistent.
It wasn't 100 percent of the time,
but it wasn't 50 slash 50.
It was more like 70,
30 rupert cherish held,
right?
Yes.
Interesting things he tells.
By the way,
that's an interesting guy.
You know what,
when the birds
in in say,
the Second World War,
uh,
getting into these mil bottles with a
silver top,
they learned to pick through
[inaudible].
And the day,
the distance between say England and the
Netherlands or Germany,
etc. Is a divided by a northern city and
these words are not able to travel the
other side to the other side,
but the same birds were able,
the same species of birds at the other
side were able to,
uh,
day began to do the same.
Yeah,
he has a term wIth monkeys and fall age
or resonance,
morphic resonance.
And what he believes is that when one
member of the species attempts to learn
something or learn something,
it becomes far easier for other members
of the species even that are separated
by vast distances to learn that.
And I think he said that occurred with
rats in a very particular maze that they
would teach rats how to get through a
particular maize in one part of the
world.
And then rats and the other part of the
world navigated it much quicker.
There's some interesting stuff when it
comes to that stuff.
I mean,
interesting.
It is interesting,
but it's hard because there's a lot of
people call bullshit and I don't know
who's right.
And you gotta kinda go over it with a
fine tooth comb and look at everybody's
looking at their motivations and look at
whether or not they're biased and it's
very difficult to sort out.
But rupert seems like a very thoughtful,
very interesting guy.
He definitely didn't seem dishonest.
Mm hmm.
So yeah.
I'm here to,
to say a little bit about what we did.
Yeah.
Tell me
a censure last year so that the goals
now are to get it into a national
healthcare.
Actually any every country but in
America is a little bit a leader there
in.
And I'm beginning to become quite
famous.
I use it,
abuse it to get my goals done,
my mission done,
which is bringing a belief,
a confidence love,
but now scientifically endorsed.
showing that we are able to tap into all
those systems and we should actually get
it in school,
in primary school to begin with.
And not only learn like history and
geography and things like that,
but now learn at a young age
how to influence into this hormonal
system and immune system or say
happiness,
strength,
health shoot be subjects.
And I teach kids of four years old with
arthritis.
They come and they are very able to do
breathing exercises going into cold,
actually children.
We teach him to have coal,
john and therefore,
uh,
taken away the stimulation of the
natural element,
thus decreasing the activity of their
systems inside.
We make them sick instead of protecting
them,
we are comforting them.
And we think that paradigm shift needs
to happen.
And I'm into that and now it's getting
together with a existent healthcare.
And with universities more and more,
I think we got to go back to say nature.
And if her mother is able to guarantee
by endorsed by scientific evidence that
we are able to tap in to all these
systems guaranteeing,
hey,
if you just breathe better and take a
cold shower and believe connect with
your body that you are able to tap into
your health,
your happiness and your strength,
then that's something that will bring
mother nature back in us and awareness
there,
uh,
from will make this world a value.
The nature outside as inside.
because we lost a connection.
And I'm now here to bring that.
And since last year I've progressed,
you know,
things like anxiety and fear,
nobody knows about.
Now I do know what it is.
I know what it is,
is biochemical and neurological.
I talk with professors,
I teach them the,
uh,
they,
teach me their language and I teach them
the method and together we get a more
out of it.
Uh,
it's all happening.
So,
uh,
I'm very thankful to be here with you.
I still got a joke.
A joke.
Yes.
I wanted to say this big ass too.
Yeah,
that's,
that's another one.
A little bit thankful to have you here
to really am a very.
I'm very appreciative.
It's not a whole lot of people that all
do a late night podcast with.
but you anytime.
Thanks.
Thanks joe.
That's great.
And I must say,
and me,
my podcast with you,
so many people,
I didn't know who you were.
I never give a fuck who I go to,
but when I get there and it starts,
my mirror is the people who are
commanding.
I never looked.
Yeah,
yeah.
I'm not looking for a job now or
whatever,
but I never go with a program.
I don't know.
They never give me too much information
either.
My adults taught my children that they
work with me.
They take god.
That did a lot.
Let them go.
Well,
I'm curious to see what the responses
this time because the difference in the
numbers of staggering.
like what was the.
What was the monthly downloads last
year?
Just take a guess.
Probably like 15,
18 million now.
It's well over 40 plus youtube shit.
Yeah,
it'll be way more.
It's more than double.
It's good.
That's good because all the world needs
to know about this.
This is simple.
Accessible,
effective scientifically and doors.
No speculation.
It's there,
but now I got this job job.
I.
I bought it to say that.
That's.
I'm with Joe Adams.
I know now a.
You said a comedian before,
so you can appreciate this.
I got to.
Joe had.
It's a big.
He's big.
He's enormous.
He is orange.
It's so rank attack an orange orangutan?
Yes.
In the middle of san francisco.
Oh,
san francisco or los angeles.
We are here,
launch it in a big city.
I mean,
in a big city,
you don't see orangutans,
they to go to the zoo,
right.
I don't know what maybe you know or
whatever.
Oh,
you traveled incognito and uh,
with a hat on.
And as soon big suit must be a bit,
but he walks over there and the sun is
shining and it's shining on his long a
orange hair.
I thought I was gonna say yeah.
But wait a minute.
HeY,
still has to come.
I
shush you over there.
Yeah,
I told you how to give them beer.
He's like a gremlin.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He doesn't know how to control it.
It's just I'm this chemistry,
he's not on audio.
Okay.
So he's dripping and ya know,
davis endocrine system and it's dripping
a long as the orange has and that it's
flickering together with the sun.
Looks like will our enormous and the
light is upon it.
And he walks a among the street and a
big lips.
Big cheek,
big claws.
Very peaceful.
He has no enemy.
He's there just by being himself and
he's easily as a bar.
And he,
in his mind,
kept pops up,
chest is
a golden bear and he sees it within.
He's already driven from it or from his
lips is coming down and he goes through
the door.
He's got quite some difficulty to get
through the though because he's so big,
really squeezes himself through the door
and there he sees his stool.
He goes through the stool.
I mean he's really big and the stool is
only so big.
So he's got a,
he's into a balancing act not to fall
through,
so,
so big a year.
But finally he gets there and he
accomplishes this balancing act and he
is there.
He's at ease.
And of course the bomber.
We flat into a corner somewhere and he
said,
hey,
hey.
Yeah,
he's at ease.
He's peaceful.
He's at ease.
Yeah.
These pieces.
We'll talk to the bartender zia money
stealing this beer.
I don't know.
He has no pockets,
but he has got money.
I don't know why he stashed it,
but it's there.
It's there.
All right.
And uh,
he,
he's very peaceful.
The orangutan show,
his fear is subsiding and he comes and
still and that he gives us to to like
this and then it gets a bear claw around
this little glass or a golden bear lake.
We're looking at it
like a little baby.
He's a dad.
He puts it back
and he puts a $100 bill on the.
On the bar,
on the,
on the tap as bar.
Yeah.
$100.
Now suddenly the bar man things what?
But because he is a very peaceful.
Is there.
You enjoy this beer?
He got a $100.
I think I'm going to give him back at my
shiny coin because he doesn't know about
the significance of,
of money and he gives him a shiny coat
and he takes the $100 bill and I don't
know where he puts it because he's got
no pockets,
but he puts it somewhere.
It looks at it and puts it somewhere and
he sits there and finally the obama got
his confidence so much.
He asks you,
hey,
what about this?
I never ever.
so a orangutang in my bar.
What is it an orangutan do know what
kind of prices you are charting
and that's the punchline and the thing
is,
the thing is this is the way we think we
can mess up with a trake,
our inner power.
WhoA,
we are straw man,
but we always think bad about who we are
in the depth
and he is there for you to enjoy life
and to be as strong as mother nature in
the future.
Yes.
I would just recommend just tightening
that up a little bit.
Oh yeah.
It's kind of a funny joke.
It's kind of funny.
I knew what was coming towards the end,
but yeah,
I'm a professional comedian.
Yes.
I knew the joke,
but joke.
Yeah.
Well I knew at the end.
I don't even think I'd heard it before,
but I knew I always extended I that I
now use it as a metaphor because that's
no joke.
That's real wood.
What's real?
That's the way we trick with our mind.
We ca where you think we can trick
mother nature inside our deeper power.
Eight or power.
Okay.
I get it.
It just,
it was a little shorter.
Probably better,
right jamie?
Yeah.
I mean it's not a bad joke.
That big asshole jokes a little better.
I think so too.
Washing elephant hit a guy with his
trunk.
I kinda knew that elephants trunks were
powerful.
I'm gonna always knew,
but I had no idea.
I.
This guy got too close to an elephant.
The elephant was eating and it just
swatted him with its trunk and he went
flipping like head over heels,
head over heels,
head over heels and it was hilarious.
He.
He knocked that thing the way you would
flip a beer.
Oh yeah.
What does with its trunk?
amazing.
Do you just the,
the,
the epic scale of those animals.
It's just unbelievable when you see the,
the amount of force that they can
generate with their nose.
Did you see it?
Yeah.
It should put it up and he didn't check
his eyes went wide.
Is his head snapped back?
What?
He saw this?
Watch this.
This guy got too close?
Yes.
He goes to touch it
still.
Yeah.
He didn't give a fuck.
He's like,
bitch,
get outta here.
Like you're bothering me.
I think as a female,
I didn't even have tusks.
It's a female or a juvenile,
but why were we are onto right now with
this research,
these findings out of,
uh,
out of nature.
And next time I will get some new
breakthroughs.
Yeah.
And we have to see each other again.
Yeah,
let's do every october.
Yeah.
It,
we didn't even play.
Let's make a deal deal october.
Let's do it.
great.
We bring that guy in and have them do 80
pushups up.
Fuck you mean by that?
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Just a free diving message board.
And there's some people that were asking
us.
The only thing I found on the entire
internet,
uh,
some guy claimed he did 72 after taking
that jack three d stuff with one brand
after taking a five minute breathing
exercise and then no breasts and you did
72 people so they'd like 40 or 50
breathing would've helped like a similar
method to this,
but they weren't talking about.
Yeah,
I have a feeling your friend might be a
little full of shit.
It just doesn't.
As an athlete,
as someone who understands the potential
of the human body,
you have to be extraordinary.
You have to be pretty extraordinary to
do 80 push ups on your own.
You have to be conditioned.
It's something like just a force,
your muscles,
depending upon how much you weigh of
course,
but if you're the average 175 pound or
whatever the average man is to just to
force yourself to do 80 pushups,
you have to be in pretty good condition.
To do that,
you have to.
That's a lot of repetition.
You're essentially,
I mean it's not like you're bench
pressing 175 pounds,
but it's probably like a bench
precedent.
One 40,
like how much would you think it would
be like a pushup?
How much you actually pushing up?
So if I weighed 200 pounds,
if I'm doing a pushup,
how much am I actually pushing because
I'm not really pushing 200 pounds
because my feet are on the ground and
you know,
there's,
there's some weight down there.
How much am I actually pushing?
It feels like I'm pushing about 130,
140 pounds when I do a push up
60 slash 70 percent of your body weight
price.
I guess.
Why don't you go try to google something
like google
percentage of your body weight or you
actually lifting when you do a pushup.
Interesting.
Yeah,
because I don't.
It's definitely not a 100
that's analyze it and I really began
with these pushups and now everybody is
health course copying and I know what a.
That's all.
Okay.
But I like to like research.
I like to investigate what we are really
doing.
Yeah.
Here we go.
Forty nine percent.
Okay.
regular pushup,
you live 64 percent of your body weight,
whereas with a knee pushup,
your pushup.
So a regular pushup,
64 percent of your body weight.
So for me it's a little over 100 was
110,
something like that?
Yeah.
One 14,
right?
Sixty four.
Is that right?
One,
28.
Okay.
So I was pretty close.
Sixty four posole.
I was pretty close.
I was thinking it was like 1:30,
1:44.
Oh,
that makes sense.
So yeah,
so that's what I thought.
I can't do 80 pushups.
I can't do any pushups.
Is breathing was I don't think I can.
I don't do pushups on much bench press,
heavier weights and I do a lot of their
stuff while scaring me without
breathing.
BreAthing.
So powerful.
I can't we do that.
What are you doIng now?
Oh,
that's it.
It's a nose.
The what's the world record pushups.
How many things the world record in a
row?
I bet it's like $300 for without leaving
the pushup position in 1987.
We did a 3000.
Seventy two times for women.
It's 300 to
3000.
You can.
You can stay there all day.
They get to.
There's no time limit on that.
Oh.
So you can go down and rest and then
push yourself back up.
Stuff up.
Probably even for like an hour if you
want it to jesus christ.
What about in a row?
What about consecutive no arrest record?
Second an hour.
Is there a consecutive most pushups?
Nonstop is 10,000.
500.
Some revelation going on.
Oh my god.
what kind of a fucking freaked as 10,000
pushups.
Wait a minute.
Look at what they're defining as
pushups.
Oh,
that's like a look at their pushups.
They don't go all the way down those
fucks.
Now,
if this is what the
counting.
Hey you gotta touch your chin.
The world record.
So it's defined though.
It's defined by a specific degree of
bend in your arms.
What counts is a pushup is it's
essentially when your arm,
your upper arm is 90 degrees.
It's when your upper arm is parallel to
the ground.
Yeah,
right.
Yeah.
And your lower arms straight up.
And now.
Huh?
Thirty $800 an hour at 3:38.
Seventy seven.
Jesus christ.
That's crazy.
That guy probably couldn't even tie his
shoes the next day.
Probably tore himself apart.
We went to,
uh,
we should get wim hoff together with
louie simmons about that.
Do you know Louis Simmons and simmons is
a madman.
He's the guy.
He's a very famous power lifter.
And every single part of his body has
been broken.
He's in his sixties and he's been on
steroids.
It's 1970.
There's louie simmons has no biceps.
I think in this picture you probably
still had biceps.
It seems like there's still there.
His biceps have torn off of the,
off of the bone.
If he lifts his arms over his head,
he blacks out because he's so damaged.
She has so much neck and,
and tissue damage is a fucking maniac.
What a character he is though.
We,
uh,
we interviewed him last month.
We went to his gym.
He's a really,
really famous powerlifter.
He's actually a genius when it comes to
the construction of exercise equipment.
We have one of his pieces of equipment
in the back.
It's called the reverse hyper.
That damn thing changed my life.
I'll show it to you afterwards.
You could see it,
it,
it actively decompresses the spine.
Say that's a,
the lifting up,
but on the lifting down it goes under
the weight,
goes underneath that bench and it
actually pulls apart your spine.
It decompresses the spine.
So all of the gravity and the stress and
all the different measures they could
see how it works.
So it's an amazing piece of equipment.
And he,
louis,
uh,
invented that.
He's got some great,
great ideas about power lifting,
but he's just like many brilliant
people.
He's fucking insane.
It's a great way and a great way.
But anyway,
you,
you and him together.
Maybe you could fix them,
get them breathing.
He wouldn't let me just start swearing,
throwing shit around,
do some steroids.
Great.
So
yeah,
I had a lot more facts going on,
really are progressing with the science
and becoming more famous and we are
reaching out more and more.
A very powerful people.
Famous people are beginning to get the
idea and they will help me in the
Indiana.
I want to do charity because I did
already the breakthroughs within the
science.
Uh,
and uh,
now I want to do charity.
Yes.
That like we were talking about Tanzania
and uh,
and the resource and the messiah and the
messiah before they were the men who are
able to stand off a line.
So they are dealing with fear.
They become a lion is able to smell fear
and uh,
animals like a,
that's reactive.
It's a,
it's our hormones,
but people have it as well.
And so that's why we go in cars through
these reserves,
etc. Now I found that that fear is
actually coming in within our
subconscious fear because we are not
acting natural anymore.
Uh,
we alienated from nature and we have
fear.
We are able to walk in a city with an
attitude,
et cetera.
But do it now in front of the line.
Then you become fearful because you know
you are not able to cope with that
situation and you have to be peaceful.
You have to be there,
but you then the line will not attack
you.
It only attacks when it's hungry and you
can see things and all,
all those things.
But if you have no fear,
you could just pass by a couple of
meters from alliance in the world.
What I'm,
yes.
And this is what I'm,
who knows this,
uh,
me and the maasai.
Have you done it?
But I,
I'm,
I'm with a massage.
Do it.
I'm with the maasai.
And uh,
they,
uh,
I'm doing this.
It's called garden garden of eden
project.
That means with really wild animals like
hyenas,
elephants,
giraffes,
lions.
I want to show you
a picture before you engage in this
ridiculous adventure.
It was a photo of.
There's a photographer that climbed out
of his jeep.
Do you see that photo?
Remember it was in the daily mail where
there's a series of photographs were a
lion was going to pounce on him.
It literally jumped towards him and
opened its mouth and this guy got
photos.
I think it was inside of like 30 or 40
feet when the lion finally stopped,
but they are some of the most terrifying
photos.
Photographer gets shots of lion before
when it almost attacked him.
See if he could find it.
I have them on my phone.
I can show it to you.
Interesting.
It was my screensaver on my phone
forever.
But you see a situation,
another situation,
a people go windows jeep through the
safari and see lions.
So about 12 of them lying there and you
go with a jeep.
Then suddenly comes to my kid on his
bike and older lights.
He him and there is to look at that
face.
Oh yeah.
Fuck that.
Whoa.
That thing.
It's way scarier than a werewolf.
You know why?
Because a lion is a lion every fucking
day of the week,
365 days a year,
as long as it's alive.
A werewolf the werewolf,
one day a month,
full moon.
That's a goddamn lie.
And fuck a werewolf.
It's kind of funny because that's way
scarier than a werewolf.
It's way bigger than a werewolf.
Interesting.
Look at the face on that thing.
Nature.
Nature is amazing.
Like that is an amazing creation.
Interest and amazing creature are able
to stand up.
I believe it when I see it.
Yes.
But the thing is,
what do you.
I want to create an agency within my
salary together and then have people
walk through it instead off a car under
guidance of under guidance of my site
under guidance of navy seals arm to the
tetes fucking missile launchers and
shit.
Yeah.
You think so that,
that helps.
But it is something definitely helps.
That's the only way I'm going.
Oh,
okay.
More and more important.
More.
Oh,
right.
Okay.
I like it.
A far more important to this to help the
homeless.
Yes.
And that's where I going to help them,
uh,
you know,
ptsd and all that.
We Are into university studies right now
dealing with that and about the
homeless,
homeless veterans,
like tony robbins,
it,
providing for like hundred million
meals.
I'm going to help wherever I can.
Of course I want to do more like there
are these soup kitchens and they,
they do don't ask money for your
participation and have say a meal,
but you can donate.
So people who are homeless,
they have no money,
right?
So they are able to eat and those who
come there and have altered meat meal,
they are not obliged to give money but
they gave it anyway and they see the
idea behind it,
the,
the charity go behind it.
And most of the times they give okay
money and it survives.
It's okay,
it works now I want these homeless
people and not only to have a soup
kitchen like that,
but also work on the land and providing
vegetables and all that for the
restaurant and this tribute as well in
the city.
I think this way we could.
It's very making them active,
not just donating and giving food,
but to get them back into,
uh,
the infrastructure,
the system,
the civilization among people.
Right.
That's it.
Well,
if you could just get them active and
give them some hope.
Right.
There's a lot of people that just,
almost.
I think there's,
there's levels of poverty and despair
and I think for some people that just
like on the edge and maybe just a little
bit of help or bring them back off the
edge and bring them back into
circulation.
You know,
I mean,
yeah,
yeah.
Many people become homeless over time
and they weren't before and then it
just,
things don't go well and I know a bunch
of,
have a bunch of comedian friends that
lived in their cars and you know,
living on people's couches and we're
real close to homeless but made it
through.
So it's even.
There's very various levels,
strange thing that a thing called
civilization and yes,
I mean homeless is a very strange thing,
right?
Like you don't have a regular place to
go.
And that in our mind is like one of the
saddest things.
Like,
oh,
you don't have a place for your shit.
Yeah.
What do you,
how do you watch tv,
get online,
do you don't even have a facebook.
You're homeless and you know,
and that's how a lot of us look at it.
We look at someone not having home.
Meanwhile the homeless person or this
person who's like a backpack or some,
you know,
person who's like a traveler,
they might be way happier and healthier
than a lot of people that you see
trapped in these homes that are sitting
there smoking cigarettes.
Absolutely.
Caring and sharing.
Yeah.
That is the thing missing.
It certainly helped a lot of people,
right?
Yeah.
And uh,
how to get to that.
Yeah.
And it's abstract now,
but I'm getting it through science.
But uh,
I did the science now.
I wanted to do charity.
That's great thing.
That is great.
Yeah.
And you helping
me right now,
I'm happy to be helping you do anything
is maybe a little bit of our society is
so competitive and that that competitive
nature sort of alienates us from the
other people around us.
We think of them as competitors rather
than think of them as our brothers and
sisters.
I think there's,
there's a,
there's a lack of clarity when it comes
to the,
the actual real amount of time that we
have here.
We don't really have that much time.
It seems like a lot of time,
but I'm 49.
How old are you?
Fifty seven.
Yeah.
It goes quick,
right?
All of a sudden it's,
you know,
I'm still gonna.
Go do fucking man.
Not saying you're not going to go fast.
IT's going fast,
but we broke through and what you did is
also very memorable bro,
bro.
It's good.
We got to bring more consciousness and
we,
we got,
we.
If we are really strong,
we protect the weak and adults who are
not able to honor a,
you know,
we give love,
we do it in our way.
You do it with,
by creating our awareness and by signs
and,
and try to do now charity and we got a
hat it on w one way or another through
inspiration.
I think that's another thing you're
doing.
You're inspiring people to do something
and take positive action and that
oftentimes is the best thing you could
do rather than to help them or to give
them help.
You are providing them with their own
self help.
What I,
I just came from san francisco now or to
meet you here I think,
uh,
once again,
ana create me to feel feelings mutual.
Thanks very much.
I,
I saw homeless people over there,
but you know,
big guys and look at good at
a certain moment.
I think san francisco.
Why don't you do something about this?
San francisco is infested with
acceptance.
They have too much acceptance.
They've gone so far over the edge that
they've made it easy for people to,
you know,
just kind of fuck off and hang out on
the street.
And then there's also the very real
problem of mental illness and a homeless
veterans.
People,
as you said before,
that a ptsd.
So there's a wide spectrum of reasons
why people become homeless,
but san francisco is very accepting of
it.
It's the most accepting city I've ever
been to when it comes to homeless
people.
But it's also one of the reasons why san
francisco is so great,
like they're so open minded.
I lived there when I was a kid.
I lived in san francisco from age seven
to 11 and it was a different san
francisco because san francisco now is
all tech giants and in billionaires in
silicon valley.
I,
I did things over there down.
Oh my god.
Real estate prices are insane.
One of the most insane places in the
world when it comes to real estate
prices.
When I was a kid it was,
it was hippies because when I was there
it was during the Vietnam war and my
stepdad was a hippie.
My mom was kind of a hippie and we lived
in a hippie neighborhood.
It was just hippies.
It was just,
it was weird.
It was like it was all gay and hippies
and it's not really like that.
Even the gay people,
like they're kind of getting pushed out
in san francisco has always kind of
synonymous with gay people.
It's not.
I mean it's more tech now than anything
else and just extraordinary wealth,
but they still are very open minded.
Very progressive.
It's very left wing,
sort of liberal kind of a town which has
its pluses and minuses,
you know,
it's just,
the tolerance is excellent.
It's really good.
but some,
I mean when you have that many homeless
people,
like something's not right.
What is that thing?
I mean I would be,
it would be very arrogant of me without
any work or investigation whatsoever to
try to give some sort of an explanation
for what it is.
But a lot of it's got to be connected to
how liberal they are.
They just so they're so open minded.
they're just accepting.
I think it is old ho problem throughout
America,
eh,
you know,
the difference between the real rich and
uh,
in the pool.
And uh,
but they did in baltimore for example,
I saw a documentary lately lately about
the shame of America and they told it
into documentary and things like that.
And now they do these programs with
meditation and breathing in this cooled
and they more yes,
in baltimore and they got a lot of
success that their mental state,
their psych is a lot better now at just
because of minding.
And that's what we need to get to school
in schooling.
Breathing mindfulness.
Yeah.
No,
there'll be an amazing thing for kids
that the people,
baltimore elementary school,
nixon's is detention for mindful
meditation that hey,
you got some amazing and children are
very able to do that.
Change lives.
Oh yes.
That can truly truly changes lives
because you,
you can give a child instead of this
horrible thing where they feel terrible
about themselves.
You give them a reset.
Absolutely.
That's awesome.
The more out of the box thinking because
the standard thInking of raising kids.
I mean I don't know what schools like in
holland where you're from,
but here in America where I went to
school,
it was terribly confining.
Like you had to think a certain way.
You hAve to study certain things.
Yeah.
You weren't interested in those things.
you,
they made you feel like a loser.
Yeah.
If you weren't interested in math,
it was boring to you to sTudy certain
things they made you feel liKe you were
a fool and you have studies that days.
Yeah,
no,
the real,
most important assets of life and
happiness strengthen,
uh,
and uh,
health will also be subjects into
school.
Boom,
bang,
and then that's creativity,
but embracing creativity as an option
for you doing something with your life.
No one ever tells you that you could,
you could be creative for a living,
that you could be a sculptor or a
painter or an artist or a musician or an
a standup comedian or an author that's
never offered up
to get a job,
work for somebody else or start your own
business and hire some people.
That is,
it's like if you look at the,
the standard places that people go once
they graduate from high school or
college,
it's usually to get a job.
So they push you in that direction.
Like this.
There's no individual attention.
You not,
you don't feel unique.
You don't feel special.
You don't feel like you have a chance of
making outside of the system.
You have to fit into the system that
they're presenting to you.
These are your college courses,
this is your college options.
You know your gpa is not so good,
so you're going to have to go here and
that's going to suck because then your
job options going to be limited or you
can go to community college and try to
bring it up and you're like,
oh my god,
all this fucking work,
and then I'm going to take a job that's
going to suck and it's just soul sucking
for me.
I mean for some people,
those options seemed like a wonderful
idea.
Yeah.
They don't offer you a lot of choices.
There's not.
There's not like the creative fields are
not embraced and I think that's a real
problem because many,
many,
many kids.
I have little tivity yes.
The means to express the soul's purpose
will they know when there's only seven
percent in the world population that is
being creative.
It was that real ad arrest has enthuses
system being almost,
you know,
percent of little children and creating
automizing the soul.
It's not letting the soul express
itself.
I mean soul.
Nobody knows what it is,
but creativity expressing your being
that,
that makes it will tow beautiful
actually,
and now it's becoming like a gray area
feeding a system and nobody knows how to
stop this.
So what this system needs to turn around
and begin to look,
how can we serve your happiness,
strength and health because strength,
a strength,
a strong,
healthy and happy people will make up a
great system.
We have gone too far.
Now we need to go back into self
awareness and we are proving.
This is simply that we are able to do so
much more direct.
Well,
I think there's just a lot of momentum
that's that is attached to our education
system and to our job options.
Once we graduated from school and this
momentum is very difficult to someone to
step away from because most of the time,
by the time someone graduates from
college,
early in debt,
you are in debt from credit cards.
You're in debt from student loans,
money,
you have to make money in order to pay
that debt off,
and so you immediately go right,
the workforce,
and then if you're tired after working
all day and most people find it very
difficult to find a way to break free
and to,
to pursue their real dreams,
whatever they are,
you know,
songwriting or it is being an author
event.
So being wim hoff.
Yeah.
I had to find my way.
What did you used to do for a living?
All kinds of things.
Like I've been a teacher and you teach a
postman english.
Yoga.
You taught yoga.
Yeah.
No kenny.
Oh,
I know stuff.
You just under a do all kinds of
exercises,
but I've seen some of the crazy poses
you can get into them.
Imagine you teach yoga has how,
say mountaineering a instructor or going
into mom to guide a mountain guiding
canyoning.
Although studying a postman,
uh,
working in a harbor harbor ship,
loading ships,
habash
many things.
Wherever I go to lay my hands because I
didn't finish any schooling.
I'm a self made man.
I speak many languages,
I buy all,
told them myself and learned a lot about
philosophy.
Which you speak right now.
Anglaise.
Besides of my own language.
Uh,
uh,
dutch,
but then also french and german and
polish and spanish and italian.
Wow.
And even japanese.
And you speak those languages as well as
you speak?
English?
No,
because she needs to practice.
If you do not use it,
you lose it.
A of a.
It's all in there.
So your primary is english and dutch or
german?
Spanish.
Dan french.
That's amazing.
And you learn these Books.
Yeah,
the books.
I'm talking to people just talking.
But what about the gRammar?
I mean,
I would imagine the difference between
take out books once you begin to
understand a couple of language or you
know,
the,
the logic of the languages and it
becomes easier to take up a language.
What did you want to do?
What I wanted to do.
It's like when you were younger right
now.
Really?
Yes.
Really looking at 10 years old,
19 years old.
And you're young man.
Really?
I wasn't into changing the world.
I was into our so far out and doing
crazy stuff.
It was like from 17 years on,
I began to go into the cold,
being inspired by anthropologists,
went into tibet and talked about the
discipline,
the buddhist.
Yeah,
the esoteric disciplines of the
buddhists or buddhism
they call cities within the yoga and all
sandy.
Oh,
cities like cities of levitation,
that's an old oh,
staying and Japan and there's some right
in moodle and all that.
I was very,
very intrigued.
Why?
Because I think they found a way to show
that the depth is existent,
but it takes years and you got to go
like a caveman in,
uh,
and uh,
and isolate a guru or adapt,
introduce yoga practices and it's old,
very secretive and uh,
and things like that.
And uh,
I was looking at internet and,
and why?
I think it has got something to do with
my birth.
It was traumatic.
It was one of the identical twin and I
was born quite too late.
Not really too late,
but it made a real psychic imprint when
I came without too much of oxygen.
Oh,
fear and trauma.
And yes,
and uh,
and too cold in a,
in a place and I was born,
delivered over there.
So I think that made a psychic imprint
which had a absolute influence in my
growing.
Uh,
and then later what's happening,
I always wear it had been looking into
psychology,
different,
uh,
disciplines say religious,
etc. Are always more interested tHan my
identical twin brother.
He's actually a normal guy working like
nine to five.
Like everybody could get him to play you
in some places where you can't get
there.
We're going to grow his hair like,
you know.
No,
not that I meet in the middle.
It's a.
Yeah,
we did,
we did tricks because we look so much
like each other.
And uh,
if he wanted to have a say even if we
can trick our mother.
What about girlfriends?
Girlfriends?
No,
no comment.
Did you,
um,
do you guys have the same amount of gray
in your beard and the whole deal stand
next to each other we say is different
now.
What does he look like?
He's more a boulder.
Matt.
I am more stressed,
but I think more stress.
Yes.
does he exercise a exercise?
Yeah,
but uh,
he took up a lot of what I am doing,
but I really,
in my mind,
I go a lot further than he is able to.
And that's interesting that you
correlate that with your birth,
that you were born after hiM and then it
was,
there was some trauma involved and yes,
some stress.
So,
uh,
absolutely.
And made a psychic print.
And later my life I began to look into
that and you know,
the first time I went into this cold
water I,
I had this connection with that trauma
because the no other way gave me
disconnection with this deep trauma and
added know where it was,
who uga inflicted it or my mother tell
her,
told me later,
and then it made sense to me.
Oh,
that'S why.
That's why I like it in the cold and
because I was born into cold,
almost suffocated.
That's why I do these breathing
exercises and feel good.
FInally I'm able to tap into that
traumatic imprint and change the
chemistry at will controlled.
And then I found out I was able to do so
much more because now I was able to do
it consciously.
And uh,
from there,
uh,
I got into the television,
then I got into the science and it
appears to be that I found also a way to
tap into what we call t trauma ptsd,
emotion,
fear,
depression,
uh,
and not only that,
auto immune diseases,
possibly cancer that we still got to
find out,
of course,
but I think they just got a.
Nature's got the solutions for us,
but we need to get back into nature and
the nature all inside.
we all got a faculties,
the abilities to wake them up and to
bring them within our control.
And now we have shown that
scientifically,
within a couple of days,
you are able to tap into all those
systems.
How far we can go,
still need staff.
What do You think about the effect of
modern civilization traffic?
Just to stress and pollution,
environmental pollution,
pollution,
the air,
things like that.
WhaT,
what,
what kind?
What kind of effect do you think that
has on absolutely wrong effect to
chemical,
a deregulation biochemical deregulation
up till the dna,
bam.
so api genetical,
uh,
not only genetically,
but uh,
during the live you talk about
epigenetics and we are able to influence
into the genome structure of the dna,
but uh,
with a existence,
smog stress,
a negative thoughts and radiation of
things.
And I don't know all these,
we mess up the chemistry.
We are dealing with chemistry and we eat
food which is now not really food
anymore.
And we got a,
we are built with our,
our systems are able to do with natural
food and natural tribal being like
taking care of each other.
Brothers and sisters like tribal.
That's the way.
And what we do now is competition is
creating a whole lot of uncontrolled
getting on us all the time.
Why to server system instead of a
happiness strength and health care.
it's not being served anymore.
Everybody running behind is there a
deadline?
And on top of that we get food,
eh,
which has no,
which has messed with.
So we create a lot of difficulties for
our physiology that works back on our
brain because it's piece of meat inside
and it's just wicking on biochemical and
we are messing with that.
So what I found in nature is actually is
shortcut who learn to cleanse all the
older pollution,
creating a wrong chemistry,
created deregulation of the dna and
causing the body not to be able to deal
with,
say,
disease,
sickness and depression and all these
things.
Do you live in nAture?
Like where,
where do you live?
I live in the city,
uh,
at right now.
I live in a little village.
A little village.
Small town?
yes.
But stressful.
Uh,
it does not matter.
I can live anywhere.
You can live in New York city,
but when you freak out all the bam bam.
Fuck you.
Oh no,
no,
no.
I used to sit as a exercise on the
middle of this choir of the one most,
uh,
traffic squares.
So for big city in the internet islands,
which is amsterdam,
and just meditate on the square and with
all the cars come and go and roll,
jude or boom,
boom,
boom.
And I actually had a greater.
Really?
Yes.
We used it as a.
An exercise.
Yes sir.
Like A stressor.
Come on.
Yeah.
So all that chaos and madness.
You found your piece inside of all that.
He really are able to distance from and
witness how it works on your systems,
your nervous system,
and the nervous system then is able to
deal with that.
He becomes so tranquil and the more it
tries to get to you.
These are all exercises of yogis,
yogis,
they sit with four.
Five,
be around them or in the cold.
What I also did and all that.
The extremes are.
It's extremely great.
The feeling which derives if we just
witness and let go,
interfering in the systems,
working with the impact of what is going
on,
which could be stressing anyway.
So you find your own inner peAce myths,
all that noise and that's the way our
mInd can work.
That's what I do when my wife tells me
boring stories.
I don't even listen.
I just go into my center.
Dang.
I have to like pay attention to the
inflection that might indicate a
question.
God dammit.
Let me and when that,
you know,
and I go,
oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Wherever we can be very stressful.
They know you.
So can men date to databank?
Queue down women are way better than men
in that regard.
Probably more stressful.
Especially if you're banging them right.
Jamie,
you know what I'm talking about.
I love them.
I love the.
I love my wife.
I love my girlfriend.
Take my wife please.
Henny youngman joke.
Uh,
so,
uh,
what else?
Going on a lot.
Should we wrap this up?
You've got to tell us.
No,
no,
no.
It's all about love and it was very
lovable to be here.
I feel no stress whatsoever.
I did buy shit,
but there's a whole lot more common,
but I think the gist of it has been
discussed,
has been gotten out and it is a life so,
so interesting.
So beautiful.
I thank you for you being a big window
for so many and uh,
thank you for being
part of it.
It means a lot to me to,
to have you come back on and means a lot
to me.
To be able to,
uh,
to share your ideas with the world and
give you a platform.
And,
um,
I think what you're doing is amazing.
It's incredible.
It's just incredible because it's so
effective and it's so scientifically
proven.
It's also incredible because it's so
rare that there's not that many people
doing this.
And if there are,
they're not talking about it the way you
are and they're not subjecting
themselves to scientific research.
And I think that's,
that's one of the more amazing things
about it because,
uh,
just like that guy.
What was your friend's name?
Scott carney is connie.
He,
of course,
you know,
you hear these stories and you probably
assume that you're some sort of a guru,
crazy person running a cult,
but then he gets to meet you and he
goes,
oh,
this is one of the rare real deals.
There's not a lot of real deals out
there.
There's not a lot of people who are
really living an extraordinary life.
And you,
wim hoff are living an extraordinary
life.
Well,
that's a great.
And as long as people like you and me
and uh,
everybody who is in the same realm
exist,
we help the ones who want to house us.
Yes,
yes.
The,
the poor and,
and,
and the week we are not able to do.
We are a strong man and you know,
the american natives,
they had got to.
You are being measured by the way you
give.
And that means not money.
It means his love,
effectiveness for children to feel no
stress and grow up for being a great
human beings because human
being a human being should be something
very,
very beautiful on this beautiful planet.
Yeah,
I agree,
man.
I tried to express to people that these
shows would not be possible if people
weren't listening.
I wouldn't do them.
Nobody would be willing to.
It's kind of an interesting thing about
podcasts because I couldn't just get you
to come here and just sit and talk to me
and nobody else would here for hours and
hours.
The,
the,
the actual mechanism of doing a podcast,
the act of doing a podcast allows me to
listen to these people like you and all
these other interesting people that I so
lucky to get to talk to,
so I benefit from it tremendously,
but it wouldn't exist without other
people listening.
So the fact that people are listening is
what makes me read these things and we
thank the people who are listening right
now.
Oh,
from our heart.
Yes,
absolutely.
Absolutely.
If it wasn't for them like that does.
That sounds so cliche.
Hey,
if it wasn't for you guys,
we couldn't do it,
but there would be no reason there'd be
no.
It wouldn't be no motivation.
If,
if it wasn't for people listening that
there would be no show,
it wouldn't exist.
I would never have met.
You have never met all the extraordinary
people that I've met.
I'm very eager to see what this is going
to do and because the last time I met
you and afterwards I hear joe rogan
everywhere,
everywhere since that.
So I came here now,
well I'm going to go to the joe rogan,
but then at the moment my bad,
that expectation,
heaviness fell off.
I'm just going to say my thing.
Yeah.
I'm being allied with him.
Just have a good time.
Like last time I had and we did.
We had a great time I think.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It was great.
You've become friends with my friend
chris ryan.
Oh yeah.
Hey.
Oh,
that's his shirt.
Shirt,
man.
Civilized to death.
Yeah.
I love chris.
He's awesome.
I do a podcast with him and duncan
trussell,
we call it the shrimp parade.
We do it.
Uh,
it's just like,
it's completely informal.
Like we'll do one episode of my podcast
and we'll do one episode of dunkin's,
one episode of chris's and we just sort
of rotate back and forth between each
other when chris was in town,
but chris was living in barcelona for a
little what?
Little bit,
but now he's back so soon.
But he,
he,
he loves you too.
He had a great time with you.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I just had a podcast with him and say a
week ago or something together with a
professor.
I don't remember his name for people
want to listen.
It's called tangentially speaking and
it's available on itunes and it's
available on a.
Is it chris ryan.com is that is a dr
chris ryan dotcom,
maybe ryan phd.com.
Chris ryan.
Phd.com.
I think that's also his twitter handle
and chris is awesome.
He's a great storyteller.
He's a brilliant,
brilliant guy and he also has a great
book.
Yeah.
What is it about the sex,
the sex of dawning of downing of sex
lives.
What is it called?
Sex at dawn.
Sex at dawn?
Yeah.
It's a great book.
Why did you throw it in the garbage?
It's so good.
My friend's wife threw it in the
garbage.
She started reading it.
She goes,
you are not reading this and chucked it
in the trash.
Yeah.
I do not agree really with this sexual,
uh,
you know,
explanations about how their day went
and why we have these urges like from
the prehistoric where you don't agree at
a scientist.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
What do you think scientists would that
right now we have a ability to
consciously choose a woman and in this
world it's not about going and
spreadsheet seed everywhere now it just
be with one woman consciously,
you know?
Yeah.
But that's not really what he's saying.
What he's saying.
He's sort of trying to explain the,
the yes,
I know the origins of these urges and I
think he's very intelligent and uh,
what he does is great work because he
wakes up a whole lot of.
He's very.
Yeah,
it's very controversial,
but it's very rooted in science.
He's got this story with this cat.
A cat.
Yeah.
Making sex with the cat.
He had sex with a cat and I tell that
story.
Tell that story.
Not really.
We got a boner as cat.
Not really that something by figuring
out what are they?
A cat.
The cat sexuality was all about it.
That's right.
I did tell those stories with my dogs.
Oh boy.
To end the show
on the lag and all that.
I mean,
we're all doing.
Wait,
wait,
wait.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I see.
Yes.
I,
I just,
because we want to find out it shouldn't
be,
you know,
taboo on sex.
Maybe we should have proper education.
Darin.
Yes.
We haven't really stopped the sexual
behavior and then it gets into these
perverted ways anyway because of the
power and it is not able to grow into
love.
Yes.
And that should be how we end this.
Yeah.
Don't suppress shit.
Be loving.
Yes sir.
Rock on wim hoff.
Right on.
Thank you my brother.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Always going to do it again next
october.
Yes.
Hello ladies and gentlemen.
Thank you.
Goodnight.
Mm.